The STL, in my opinion, is a singular work of genius. What do you think it was about the STL that made it so novel? A sense of searching for some underlying truth. Yeah, no, no. We have more time than that because it's just my mom and I do yoga twice a week, as Connor knows. Oh, that is very cool. She's pretty flexible. Wow.
在我看来，STL 是独一无二的旷世杰作。你觉得 STL 是有什么特质才让它显得如此新颖？一种对某种底层真理的探索感。对，没错。我们有的是时间，因为就像康纳（Connor）知道的那样，我和我妈一周做两次瑜伽。哦，那太酷了。她身体挺柔軟的。哇。
Good one. Good one. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 48 recorded on October 3rd, 2021. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host Bryce, we have on special guest Dave Abrahams. And we talk about how C++ now aka BoostCon got started and his work on the C++ and Swift programming languages. Well, you know, it's funny, the one of the things that I am best known on the committee for is my my passionate speech for why we should not standardize the 2D graphics library. And during that, I said at some point we have to draw a line, let's draw a line about like what we're going to include or not. And I did not mean for it to be, you know, a cute pun, but everybody in the room just groaned.
说得好。说得好。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 48 期，录制于 2021 年 10 月 3 日。我是康纳。今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们邀请到了特别嘉宾戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）。我们聊了 C++ now（又名 BoostCon）是如何起步的，以及他在 C++ 和 Swift 编程语言方面的工作。嗯，你知道，这很有趣，我在委员会中最广为人知的事情之一，就是我曾激情演讲，反对将 2D 图形库标准化。在那期间，我说过在某个时刻我们必须划一条线，让我们就包含什么或不包含什么划定一条界限。我并不是故意要把它说成是一个俏皮的双关语，但房间里的每个人都发出了一声呻吟。
And people, you know, I got such praise afterwards for my cleverness that I was like, I just want to tell people. Of course, now I've ruined it. Only for our listener. our listener, yes, our listener who, who may or may not be a fan. Um, all right. So it's a kind of, I guess you should do a little bit of an intro. So this is, this is how I was going to start. This is say that, uh, Bryce, you've known Dave. Um, I mean, Dave and I have, I think, peripherally seen each other on Twitter. I don't think we've ever actually spoken in a meeting directly to each other. Although obviously I know who Dave is by reputation.
然后人们，你知道的，我因为我的机智在事后受到了极大的赞扬，以至于我想告诉大家。当然，现在我把它给毁了。只为了我们的听众。我们的听众，是的，我们的听众，他们可能是也可能不是粉丝。嗯，好吧。所以这是一种，我想你应该做一个简单的自我介绍。所以这是，这是我要开始的方式。这就是说，嗯，布莱斯，你认识戴夫。嗯，我是说，戴夫和我，我想在 Twitter 上有过一些边缘交集。我想我们从来没有在某个会议上直接对彼此说过话。尽管显然我知道戴夫的名气很大。
So I think we should let Bryce do the introduction of Dave. And then the first follow-up question will be, Dave, take us back to whatever year you want to take us back to, to give us the, I'm super looking forward to hearing the history of everything you've been involved in. Cause as folks that are familiar with Dave, I won't spoil Bryce's introduction, but you've worked on a ton of cool projects, started conferences, et cetera. And you've, you've, you've definitely been around and um yeah so i i uh i'm super excited i've been looking forward to this to to get to hear the behind the scenes of not just the the
所以我觉得我们应该让布莱斯来介绍一下戴夫。然后接下来的第一个问题是，戴夫，带我们回到你想回到的任何一年，给我们讲讲——我非常期待听到你参与过的所有事情的历史。因为作为熟悉戴夫的人，我不会剧透布莱斯的介绍，但你参与过大量酷炫的项目，创立了各种会议等等。你确实，确实经历丰富，而且，嗯，是的，所以我，我，我超级兴奋，我一直很期待这个，能够听到幕后故事，不仅仅是那些
the bullet points but um yeah so bryce i'll throw it to you and then and then we'll throw it to dave i'm i'm i think i'm i knew dave from like my earliest days in programming because i got involved in boost very early on. And that was the time that Dave was, you know, was still Mr. Boost. And that was, you know, when, when Dave was working at boost pro, but I think we first must've met at boost con 2011, which was the last boost con before it became C plus plus now. Yeah. Cause that must've been where I met Dave first. And,
那些要点，嗯，是的，所以布莱斯，我把它交给你，然后，然后我们再交给戴夫。我，我想我从编程的最早阶段就认识戴夫了，因为我很早就参与了 Boost。那时候戴夫，你知道的，依然是 Boost 先生。那是，你知道的，当戴夫在 Boost Pro 工作的时候，但我想我们第一次见面肯定是在 2011 年的 BoostCon 上，那是它变成 C++ now 之前的最后一届 BoostCon。是的，因为那一定是我第一次见到戴夫的地方，而且，
you know, all the other C++ folks, John Kaub, Marshall Clow, you know, everybody else who I've known now for like 10 years. And then, you know, I guess, Dave, how many years after that did you go off to do Swift? I started that in 2013. Yeah, yeah. So it was two, yeah, because you were at the first C++ now, and then you departed. And I guess I didn't have the full perspective at the time because, you know, I wasn't on the C++ committee. I didn't, you know, I wasn't involved in C++11, but, you know, Dave was a, you know, a large part of that.
你知道的，所有其他 C++ 的伙伴们，约翰·考布（John Lakos）、马歇尔·克洛（Marshall Clow），你知道的，其他我认识了大概 10 年的每个人。然后，你知道的，我想，戴夫，那之后几年你才去做了 Swift？我是在 2013 年开始的。对，对。所以是两年，对，因为你在第一届 C++ now 上，然后你就离开了。我想我当时并没有全面的视角，因为，你知道的，我不在 C++ 委员会里。我没有，你知道的，我没有参与 C++11，但是，你知道的，戴夫是其中的很大一部分，
But then went off to- Sorry about that. We talk about Lambdas are amazing. Went off to build Swift. Yeah, I didn't have anything to do with lambdas. I gave you the static exception specification thingies, the no-throw things, and move semantics. Yeah, move semantics are big. Yeah, they're big. I would argue the biggest feature in C++ 11.
但随后去——抱歉打断一下。我们谈到 Lambda 表达式是多么惊艳。去开发 Swift 了。是的，我跟 Lambda 没有任何关系。我给你们带来的是静态异常规范之类的东西，那个 no-throw（不抛出）的东西，还有移动语义。是的，移动语义很重要。是的，它们很重要。我认为这是 C++ 11 中最重要的特性。
Yep. What about auto? Sorry about all of that. I made some mistakes. So I guess maybe, so I think this is actually an interesting place to start because I heard a story about the origin of Boost at some other C++ event recently. And I'm not sure if it's historically accurate. In particular, it was regarding the origin of the name of Boost. Yeah, well, so you know I wasn't there. I mean, I've only heard the story secondhand also. You weren't there? I thought that- I wasn't there when Robert Klarer and Beeman Dawes had this conversation.
对。还有 auto 呢？抱歉打扰了。我犯了一些错误。所以我想也许，所以我觉得这实际上是一个有趣的切入点，因为我最近在另一个 C++ 活动上听到了一个关于 Boost 起源的故事。而且我不确定它是否符合历史事实。特别是，它是关于 Boost 这个名字的起源。是的，嗯，所以你知道我不在场。我是说，我也只是听别人转述这个故事。你不在场？我以为——罗伯特·克拉勒（Robert Klarer）和比曼·道斯（Beman Dawes）进行这次对话时我不在场。
Oh, for some reason, I thought that you were one of the folks that was there that was one of the initial founders. Well, I mean, I was involved immediately after that. But this first conversation that they were having, Yeah, I wasn't at that. So when was that? I don't remember, frankly. Let's see. It must have been just after 98 because we standardized C++. And the reason that Boost came about was that Beeman, who was really was a groundbreaking piece of work, but it was also not the way we were supposed to do things. We were supposed to be standardizing
哦，不知为什么，我以为你是当时在场的最初创始人之一呢。嗯，我是说，在那之后我马上就加入了。但他们进行的第一次对话，是的，我不在那。那是什么时候？坦白说我不记得了。让我想想。那一定是在 98 年之后不久，因为我们刚刚对 C++ 进行了标准化。而 Boost 产生的原由是，比曼（Beeman）——那确实是一项具有开创性的工作，但它也不是我们原本应该做的事情。我们本该去标准化
existing practice stuff that had actually a best marginal use at that point and in fact they you know based on what Alex Steppenup said he needed there were a bunch of features added to C++ that no compiler had even implemented yet when we standardized C++. So, yeah. So we didn't want to repeat that. And so Beeman's thinking was, let's get some libraries out there that are high quality, standardizable, and go into wide use.
现有的实践，那些在当时其实只有微乎其微边际效用的东西。事实上，他们，你知道的，根据亚历克斯·斯特潘诺夫（Alex Stepanov）所说他需要的东西，C++ 中添加了一堆特性，当我们将 C++ 标准化时，甚至没有任何编译器实现过它们。所以，是的。所以我们不想重复这一点。因此比曼的想法是：让我们推出一些高质量的、可标准化的、并能被广泛使用的库。
And they're basically try to lower the barriers to entry as much as possible so that a lot of people use them. And I think we succeeded in that. Boost seems to be everywhere. Yeah. Well, not only is Boost everywhere, but a large chunk of the C++ standard library additions in C++ 11, 14, 17 all came from Boost libraries. Although it's interesting, you know, the point that you make that standardizing the STL was not really what the committee was supposed to do because, you know, it was successful. It was a risk, but it was successful. And, one of the frustrations I've had with C++ committee is the, is a kind of unwillingness to form a consensus about, about how the committee would operate and, you know, how bold to be what, you know, how important is breaking code, how important is
它们基本上是试图尽可能降低进入门槛，以便很多人能够使用它们。我认为我们在这方面成功了。Boost 似乎无处不在。是的。嗯，不仅 Boost 无处不在，而且 C++ 11、14、17 中 C++ 标准库的大量新增内容都来自 Boost 库。尽管这很有趣，你知道的，你所指出的——标准化 STL 并不是委员会本该做的事情，因为，你知道的，它成功了。这是一个冒险，但它成功了。而且，我对 C++ 委员会一直以来的不满之一，就是某种程度上不愿意就委员会如何运作以及如何表现得激进形成共识，你知道的，破坏代码有多重要、性能有多重要，所有这些类型的决策，你知道的，为了给未来的决策制定一个框架。从来没有人愿意这么做。而且，我认为这是委员会的一个重大，重大问题，但公平地说，就过于保守而言，你知道的，在我看来，STL 是一个独一无二的旷世杰作。我是说，你知道的，它在，你知道的，距离它问世已经过去多少年了？20年？算了吧，从 98 年到 2021 年，30 年。好吧。带着 30 年的后见之明，对吧？它绝对是，如果让我重新设计，我会把某些东西设计得不一样。它有一些丑陋的角落，无论如何，但是，你知道的，那种值得这样去赌一把的东西，可能几代人才出一个。
performance, any of these kinds of decisions, you know, to set a framework for future decision making. No one has ever wanted to do that. And, and that's, I think, a major, a major problem with the committee, but in fairness, with respect to being too conservative, you know, the STL in my opinion is a singular work of genius. I mean, you know, it has in, you know, with how many years has it been since it came out? 20 years? With, let's see, 98 to 2021, 30 years. Okay. With 30 years of hindsight, right? It's definitely, you know, I would have designed some things differently. It's got some ugly corners, whatever, but, uh, you know, those things worth gambling on like that come along once in a
好吧。我当然觉得是这样的。你，你，你觉得 STL 是有什么特质才让它显得如此新颖，或者说是什么，是什么，是的，是什么让它如此新颖、成功或是如此天才？嗯，我是说，你知道的，亚历克斯·斯特潘诺夫，你知道的，你不需要多说什么了。如果你听过亚历克斯演讲，并且真正了解他所了解和思考的内容，除了是一个博学多才的奇才，能够阅读古希腊语原文之外，他的，我认为他带来的、我自从遇到他以来一直带在身边的最根本的东西，
generation, maybe. Yeah. Yeah. I certainly think that's true. What, what what what do you think it was about the stl that made it so so novel or or what what what is yeah what what made it so novel or successful or so so genius well i mean you know alex stepanov uh you know you don't need to say much more than that. If you've, if you've heard Alex talk and, and really know about what he, what he knows about and what he thinks about, I mean, aside from being an amazing polymath who, you know, can read things in the original ancient greek um and uh his he i think the the fundamental thing that
是一种对某种底层真理的探索感，而不是去设计某种东西。你知道的，亚历克斯，STL 的天才之处在于亚历克斯没有说：“我要拿出一个漂亮的、能够实现这些东西的设计。看看我做了什么。”他说：“看看世界上实际存在着的东西是什么。让我们从中进行归纳。让我们找出其中实际存在的抽象。”这就是他在设计中所带的一种谦逊，我认为这（真的很关键）。是的。所以，正如我们刚才所说，在 2013 年，你加入了苹果，并开始着手这个，你知道的，这个新项目 Swift。那么，嗯，那是什么样的体验？你知道，
that he brings brought to the table that i've you know carried with me ever since i i met him is a sense of searching for some underlying truth, you know, rather than, rather than designing something, you know, Alex, the genius of the STL was that Alex didn't say, you know, I'm going to come up with a beautiful design that's, that accomplishes these things. Look at what I've done. He says, look at what's actually there in, in the world. Let's find, let's generalize from that. And let's, let's find the, the actual abstractions that are there. And that's a kind of humility that he brought to design that I think is, you know, really crucial. Yeah. And so, as we said earlier, in 2013, you went to join Apple and you got started on this, you know, this new project Swift. Um, and so what, uh, what was that like? You know, you,
没有多少人能说自己曾经历过，你知道的，像 Swift 这样以如此惊人的速度走向成熟的语言的真正诞生。所以，也许给我们讲讲你对 Swift 的体验吧。是的，嗯，对一个对语言设计感兴趣的人来说，这是一个一生只有一次的机会，你知道的，因为语言每周都在涌现，然后又在默默无闻中消亡。所以，你知道的，如果你在这个圈子里待了几年并见证了这一切，只有当你认为某个语言项目真的很有前途时，你才会想投入其中。
there aren't many people who can say that they were at the, um, you know, the, the real, the start of a language that has grown as quickly to maturity as Swift has. And yeah, so maybe tell us a little bit about your experience with Swift. Yeah, well, I mean, it was a once in a lifetime opportunity for somebody who's interested in language design, you know, because languages do come along every week and they die in obscurity. So, you know, so if you've been around a few years and seen this, you only want to get engaged in a in a language project if you think it's really got some legs.
而且，你知道的，这个项目背后有苹果的未来。苹果将自己的未来押在了它上面，尽管在早期阶段这种程度并不是完全清晰。嗯，而且它有一群了不起的人，我对他们充满信心，首先是我的密友道格·格雷格（Doug Gregor）。嗯，是的。那是什么体验？那是一场惊心动魄的冒险，你知道，嗯，那里，你知道的，它是充满拼劲的，我们有一群大约 10 到 12 人吧，我猜，可能甚至开始的时候还没有那么多，可能也就 8 个人左右。
And, you know, this one had Apple's future behind it. Apple was staking its future on it, although to what extent wasn't entirely clear in the early days. Um, uh, and it had an amazing group of, of people, uh, that I had faith in, you know, starting with Doug Greger, who was my close friend. Um, and, uh, yeah. So what was it like? It was, uh, it was a thrilling adventure um you know um there it was you know it was scrappy we had a a group of about 10 to 12 i guess uh that maybe wasn't even the the starting size might have been like eight.
但是，你知道的，克里斯·拉特纳（Chris Lattner）值得称赞的一点是，他在最大可能范围内通过共识来管理这个项目。虽然，你知道的，有些人贬低委员会设计。我一直发现，例如在 C++ 委员会内部达成共识的过程，其利大于弊。所以我们为很多事情争吵过，嗯，我们从彼此身上学到了很多。团队中有数量惊人的、不同背景的经验。是的，而且，这是一场惊心动魄的体验，但当我到达那里时，这门语言极其不成熟，用它构建任何泛型代码几乎是不可能的。而且，嗯，所以，所以前几个月，我可以说相当令人沮丧，因为这个。这使得取得进展变得非常困难。
But, you know, Chris Lattner, to his credit, ran the thing very much by consensus as much as possible. And while, you know, some people denigrate design by committee. I have always found that the process of coming to consensus inside the C++ committee for example, has been more beneficial than, than harmful. Um, and so we had a lot of fights about things. Um, uh, we all learned a lot from each other. There was an amazing amount of, uh, of different experiences in the group. Um, yeah. And, and it was, it was a thrill, but when I got there the the language was uh extremely immature it was almost impossible to build anything generic um with it and and uh yeah so so the first the first few months i would say were quite frustrating because of that. It made it really hard to make progress.
能够参与设计讨论并推动设计向前发展是一件好事。所以那很棒。但我也负责标准库。你怎么能在一个几乎无法工作的脆弱基石上构建标准库呢？嗯，而且，嗯，在某个时刻，你知道的，无法交付任何东西的压力对我和来说变得太大了，我决定，好吧，我要做我一直对破损的 C++ 编译器做的事情，那就是弄清楚如何，你知道的，强迫它们做我需要的事情。谁在乎它是不是漂亮，甚至是正确的，你知道的。所以这让我度过了一个难关。
And it was good to be part of the design discussions and move the design forward. So that was great. But I was also responsible for the standard library. And how do you build a standard library on a fragile foundation that barely works? Um, uh, and, uh, at some point, uh, you know, the, the pressure of not delivering anything became too much for me and I, and I decided, okay, I'm just going to do what I have always done with broken C++ compilers, which is figure out how to, you know, coerce them into doing what I need. And who cares if it's beautiful or even correct, you know. So that got me over a hump.
当我第一次能够构建一个数组时。那可真是一回事。是的，我的意思是我猜构建数组的初期确实是一个挑战。而且你曾参与了 C++、Swift 泛型系统的一些设计，对吧？有一点。是的，绝对的。我有过一些影响，尤其是在后期。我想说，泛型系统最初设计的很多灵感来自于杰里米·西克（Jeremy Siek）在某个叫做 System G 的东西上所做的工作，我想是这样的。基本上，据我所知，他所做的是在独立编译的情况下构建一个泛型系统。在这个意义上，就像 Haskell 所做的那样，只不过带有关联类型，
When I was first able to build an array. That was something. Yeah, I mean, I guess it really is early days of building an array is, you know, is a challenge. And you were involved a bit in the design of C++, of Swift's generic system, right? A bit. Yeah, definitely. I had some influences, especially later on. I would say that a lot of the inspiration for the initial design of the generic system came from work that Jeremy Seek had done on something called System G, I think. And basically what he was doing, as far as I understand it, was building a generic system with separate compilation. And in the sense that Haskell does it, except with associated types,
而至少标准 Haskell 是没有关联类型的。而且我认为道格把这作为了一个基础。这在苹果之所以如此重要的一部分原因，或者说对 Swift 而言，是因为 Swift 需要保留 Objective-C 对苹果而言真正具有杀手级品质的一大特性——这就是在不破坏代码的情况下升级接口两侧的能力。因此，并且无需重新编译。这是一个继续困扰 C++ 生态系统和 C++ 演进的挑战。对。是的。所以这就是他们所说的韧性或 ABI 韧性。
which at least standard Haskell doesn't have. And, and I think Doug took that as, as a foundation. And part of the reason that was so important at Apple was, or for Swift, was that Swift needed to not lose the one really killer quality that Objective-C had for Apple, which is this ability to upgrade either side of an interface without breaking code. So, and without recompiling. A challenge that continues to plague the C++ ecosystem and the evolution of C++. Yep. Yeah. So that's what they called resilience or ABI resilience.
为了做到这一点，你必须能够将泛型独立编译为某种东西，当你用不同的参数类型调用它们时，这种东西不会改变。是的，我的意思是我认为 Swift 的这一部分是一个非常好的例子，我们在 C++ 中有一些关于 ABI 问题的讨论。有些人觉得，好吧，我们应该直接去破坏 ABI 或者不破坏 ABI。而且几乎，这种对话通常让人觉得这仅仅是一个政策问题。对我来说，从来都不是，它似乎总是缺少关于我们拥有的技术局限性的讨论，你知道的，这不是一种从底层为之设计的语言。谁知道呢，也许现在为 C++ 引入某种韧性还为时已晚。但我认为，
And so to do that, you have to be able to separately compile generics into something that doesn't change when you invoke them with different parameter types. Yeah. I mean, I think this part of Swift is a really good example of, we have some talk in C++ about the ABI problem. And some people are like, well, we should just go and break ABI or not break ABI. And it's almost, the conversation is usually one that makes it seem like it's simply a policy question. To me, it's never, it's always seemed like there's been a missing discussion about the technical limitations that we have that, you know, we don't really, it's not something that was the language was designed for from the ground up. And who knows, maybe it's not too late to bring some sort of resiliency to C++. But I think
当然，如果你从语言之初就进行设计，那就容易多了。你知道，我们将要添加到 C++ 中的几乎任何形式的韧性所带来的问题之一是，与以非韧性方式做事相比，它是否会有某种成本？如果它确实有一些成本，那么你如何让人们接受并使用它呢？当然，问题之一是，一些正在做出将影响你是否能够更改 ABI 的选择的人，他们在编写代码时可能并没有意识到他们需要韧性。是的。所以所有这些事情对 Swift 来说也是真正的问题。
it's much easier, of course, if you design it from the start of your language. You know, one of the problems that would come from almost any form of resiliency that we'd add to C++ is, would it have some cost over doing things the non-resilient ways? And if it did have some costs, then how would you get people to buy into using it? And one of the problems, of course, is that some people who are making the choices that will impact whether or not you can change your ABI, they may not realize when they're writing their code that they needed resiliency. Yeah. So all of these things are real problems for Swift too.
我是说，泛型边界处的 ABI 韧性确实存在性能成本，因为这意味着你最终会得到某种动态分发。即使它是静态多态，你在功能上也最终会像在实现中那样，通过动态分发根据输入类型选择一种或另一种实现。现在，你可以通过拥有 JIT 来缓解其中一部分问题，对吧？或者某种延迟重新编译，从而消除韧性边界处的成本。但无论如何，你必须考虑到，带有底层多态性的每一个韧性边界，甚至静态多态性，都有一个虚函数调用。
I mean, ABI resilience at generic boundaries is a definite performance cost because what it means is that you end up with some kind of dynamic dispatch. Even though it's static polymorphism, you end up with functionally, like in the implementation, a dynamic dispatch that chooses one implementation or another based on the input types. Now, one thing you can do to mitigate some of that is to have a JIT, right? Or some kind of late recompilation that erases the cost at the resilience boundaries. But regardless, you have to think of it, every resilience boundary with polymorphism behind it, even static polymorphism has a virtual function call.
而且，你知道的，泛型编程所依赖的事情之一是，能够将非常小的操作（如整数或指针的自增）隐藏在抽象边界之后，无论在 C++ 术语中概念要求是什么。因此，当你为微小的操作支付动态分发的成本时，你的代码就会变慢很多。因此，关于诸如声明此项为可内联（inlinable）之类的事情，你在 Swift 中可以遇到所有这些折中点。如果你说它是可内联的，那么韧性边界就消失了。但话又说回来，你就不能更改它了。对吧？对，对。而且我认为库演进的整个问题是 Swift 尚未真正解决的事情。
And, you know, one of the things that generic programming depends on being able to hide very small operations like the increment of an integer or a pointer behind an abstraction boundary, whatever the concept requirement is in C++ terms. And so when you pay the cost of a dynamic dispatch for tiny operations, your code gets a lot slower. So there are all of these halfway points that you can get into with Swift with regard to things like saying that this thing is inlinable. If you say it's inlinable, then the resilience boundary goes away. But then again, you can't change it. Right? Yeah, yeah. And I think the whole question of library evolution is something Swift hasn't yet really addressed.
它解决了如何构建 ABI 以便你可以扩展结构体而不破坏代码的问题。但我认为，库开发人员为了能够有效地演进他们的库，还需要一整套工具和流程，而 Swift 认为它还没有做任何事情来真正深入研究这些。他们手头还有很多其他事情要处理。是的。
It's addressed the problem of how do you build an ABI so that you can extend a struct without breaking code. But there's a whole universe, I think, of tools and processes that library developers need to have in order to be able to effectively evolve their libraries, which I don't think Swift has done anything to actually dig into yet. They've had a lot of other stuff on their plate. Yeah.
我是说，有没有哪门语言是你认为适合此类工具的良好原型模型？哦，没有。我不认为，据我所知，还没有人真正试图弄清楚这一点。而且我认为从创建 ABI 韧性的能力开始是很重要的。所以我认为 Swift 处于一个独特的地位，至少拥有这样一个平台。但是，是的，我认为还有很多工作要做。我是说，是的，很多语言，包括许多新语言，你知道都在为此苦恼。我知道现在在 Rust 世界中，关于 ABI 和韧性有很多讨论，我将拙劣地总结一下我的理解，那就是很长一段时间以来，Rust 中的模型本质上是——我们不，你知道的，我们不提供，我们不担心 ABI 稳定性。现在可能有一些人对此产生了一些疑问。他们正在弄清楚他们究竟该如何做到这一点，特别是在一个他们以静态方式构建一切的世界里。对。是的。好吧，对于像 C++ 和 Rust 这样注重性能的语言来说，一个有趣的答案是告诉人们如何构建可以扩展的 API 并给他们一些保证，不要把这作为默认设置。对。对。所以有些事情我们在 C++ 中一直在做，我们是从 C 那里继承来的，你知道的，你构建一个 C 接口，你动态分配你的结构体，
I was going to say, is there a language that you think is the good archetypal model for those kinds of tools? Oh, no. I don't think, as far as I know, nobody has really tried to figure that out. And I think starting with the ability to create ABI resilience is important. So I think Swift is in a unique position, at least of having that as a platform. But yeah, I think there's a lot of work left to do. I mean, yeah, a lot of languages, including a lot of new languages you know struggle with this i know that right now in the rust world there's a lot of conversations going on about abi um uh resiliency and um i'm gonna badly summarize my understanding which is that for a long time the model and
然后你可以随时扩展该结构体。这些技术在实践中确实在一定程度上起作用。它们的某些部分可能是得到保证的。我不知道。是的。比如 C++ 中的一个好例子，就是像 std::mutex。所以，在 MSVC 上，他们的 std::mutex 实现是——它比他们的 std::shared::mutex 大 8 到 10 倍，而且速度慢了两倍，原因是因为他们的 std::mutex 必须向后保持 ABI 兼容，一直兼容到 Windows 的旧 mutex 布局，这是一个使用这个
rust had essentially been we're not you know we don't provide, we don't worry about ABI stability. And now there's maybe some question that there's some folks who might want that. And they're trying to sort out how exactly would they do that, especially in a world where they sort of statically build everything. Yeah. Yeah. Well, one interesting answer for for performance oriented languages like C++ and Rust is tell people how to build APIs that can be extended and give them some guarantees,'t don't make that the default. Right. Right. So there are things that we do in C++ all the time, which we get from C, you know, you build a C interface, you, you dynamically allocate your struct,
非常古老 API 的巨大东西。幸运的是，任何人都不应该使用互斥锁。是的。但如果他们在实现时，不是让该互斥锁的元数据仅仅是 std::mutex 的常规数据成员，而是把它放在某个不透明的结构体中并只保留一个指向它的指针，那么要避免这个问题其实是一件很简单的事情。只是当他们进行实现时，他们没有做出这个决定。并且你知道的，在另一个间接层面上这需要权衡。
then you can extend the struct anytime you want. Those kinds of techniques actually work in practice to some extent. They, parts of them may be guaranteed. I don't know. Yeah. Like a good example of this in C++, which is, would be like std mutex. So on, on MSVC, their std mutex so on um on msvc their std mutex implementation is like it it's eight it's 10 times larger than their std shared mutex and it's like two times slower and the reason is because their std mutex has to be be abi compatible back to like the windows x mutex layout, which is like this huge thing that uses this
但我认为，这或许是我们最初开始对 C++ 进行标准化时应该更有意识地去设计的东西。对。是的。好吧，我的意思是，这取决于每个单独的实现，对吧？是的。臭名昭著的 std::string ABI 破坏穿过委员会时你在场吗？我对这个故事不熟悉，至少不是用这些术语。这是——所以在 C++11 中，我们更改了 std::string 的一些复杂度保证，以至于它禁止了 GCC 的写时复制（copy-on-write）实现
very old API. Fortunately, no one should ever use a mutex. Yeah. But it would have been a fairly simple thing to avoid this problem if they had just, instead of having the, the, the, you know, the, the metadata for that mutex be just regular data members of std mutex, they could have just put it in some opaque struct and just had a pointer to it. It's just that when they did their implementation, they didn't, they didn't make that decision. And there was, you know, there was a trade-off to that at another level of indirection.
符合 std::string 的要求。哦，是的，我记得，我想我记得有很多关于——关于当时那个问题的抱怨，我想我记得人们说你实际上无法使写时复制实现符合标准。对。对。有趣的是，我交谈过的那个时代的所有人都不记得在更改要求时这是一个有争议的事情。直到后来我们才意识到这是一个多么重大的改变，以至于它最终减缓了 C++11 的采用，因为如果你升级到 C++11，升级到符合标准的 C++11 std::string，它就会——它将是一个 ABI 破坏，而且 std::string 到处都在使用。并且我认为这只是，你知道的，我们今天在委员会中绝对不会做出这样的改变，因为我们对 ABI 变化变得超级敏感，以至于
But I think it's something that we perhaps should have designed for more consciously when we, when we first started standardizing C++. Yeah. Yep. Well, I mean, that's, that's up to each individual implementation, right? Yeah. Were you around when the infamous stud string ABI break came through the committee? I'm not familiar with this story, so at least not in those terms. This was, so in C++11, we changed some of the complexity guarantees on std string in such a way that it prohibited the GCC copy on write implementation
几乎任何会以某种方式破坏 ABI 的提案都是行不通的。但是，你知道的，并不总是这样的。我们只是不知道，我们当时没有意识到成本是什么。好吧，至少，我是说，归功于你，我想至少现在关于什么才是重要的已经达成了一些共识，对吧？我是说，我认为在那个 ABI 破坏发生的时候，它相当随机。我们愿意在这里破坏 ABI，不在那里破坏 ABI。出于什么原因？你知道，根本没有价值规模的概念。但是，我确实认为，不愿意破坏 C++ 的 ABI，可能是它演变成一门更好语言的一个严重限制。
from conforming to what std string was. Oh yeah, I think I remember, I think I remember lots of complaints about the, about the, at that time, I think I remember people saying that you couldn't actually make a copy on write implementation conform. Right. Right. It, what, what, what's interesting to me is that, uh, everybody who I've ever talked to from that era doesn't remember it as being a controversial thing at the time that the requirements were changed. It was only afterwards that we realized how significant of a change it was, that think that it ended up slowing down adoption of C++11 because if you upgraded to C++11 to the, you know, the compliant C++11 std string, it would, you know, it would be an ABI break and std string gets used everywhere. And I think it's just, you know, it's, we would never today in the committee, we would never make such a change because we've become super sensitive to ABI changes to the
是的。我是说，我认为这仍然是 C++ 库演进的一种存在主义的挣扎和问题。因为只要我们生活在一个在我们发布错误之后无法修复它们的世界里，这就会使委员会对我们发布的东西变得非常、非常谨慎。因此，我认为标准库将大致继续保持与今天相同的规模和范围，因为任何形式的大规模扩展都会带来令人无法接受的风险程度。所以这就好象我们，我们，我们都理解这些规则，或者说不是规则。我们今天都理解这些当前的，你知道的，政策和共识以及这背后的含义。但我认为，仅仅因为我们
degree that almost any proposal that would in some way, shape or form break ABI is a non-starter. But, you know, it wasn't always that way. We just didn't know, we didn't realize what the costs were at the time. Well, at least, I mean, to your credit now, I guess at least there's some consensus about what's important, right? I mean, I think at the time that ABI break happened, it was fairly random. We were willing to break ABI over here, not over there. For what reasons? You know, there was no sense of what the scale of values was. So, but I, I do think that, that, you know, an unwillingness to break the ABI of C++ is, is a, probably a serious limitation on it being, you know, evolving into a better language.
理解了这一点，并不一定意味着结果就是最好的。好吧，为什么你不能只标准化那些在设计时考虑到韧性的库组件呢？对。我认为这是我们需要去做的事情。但这并不是我们真正涉足的领域。而且我认为很多时候，存在性能权衡。总是这样。不是经常，是总是。但如果你想要韧性，你就必须愿意做出这种权衡。一个例子是，最近在 C++ 中有很多关于标准化网络（networking）的讨论。一个经常出现的问题是，如果我们标准化某种安全网络、某种 TLS 层，好吧，当然，那会
Yeah. I mean, I think it does still remain sort of an existential, the existential struggle and question of the C++ library evolution. Because as long as we live in a world where we cannot fix our mistakes after we ship them, that will make the committee very, very cautious about what things we ship. And so I think that the standard library will roughly continue being the same size and scope as it is today, because any sort of massive expansion would, a degree of risk that would just be unacceptable. And so it's like we, we, we all understand the rules or not rules. We all understand the, the current, you know, policies and consensus and like the implications of that today. But I think just because we,
需要以这样一种方式进行标准化：我们将能够推出安全修复程序并弃用旧协议等。我的意思是，我认为我们可以做到。我认为如果我们坐下来，如果我们从一开始就说，嘿，这个库组件需要具备对更改的韧性，我们就可以这样设计它。可能会有一些性能权衡，但这是可以做到的。
we understand that it doesn't necessarily mean that the outcomes are the best. Well, why can't you just standardize library components that are designed with resilience in mind? Right. And I think that's something that we need to be doing. But it's not an area that we've really treaded into. And I think that oftentimes, there's the performance trade-off. Always. Not often, always. But if you want the resiliency, you have to be willing to make that trade-off. One example, there's been a lot of talk recently in the C++ about standardizing networking. And one question that always comes up is if we standardize some sort of secure networking, some sort of TLS layer, well, of course, that would
而且我认为很多时候，C++ 委员会中的讨论只是——好吧，这是一个 ABI 破坏，所以我们不能这样做。我们或许需要进行更多的讨论，讨论我们如何能够构建这个新组件使其具有韧性？有道理。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
need to be standardized in a way where we would be able to roll out security fixes and deprecate old protocols, et cetera. And I mean, I think we could do it. I think that if we sat down and if we said from the start, hey, this library component needs to be something that's going to be resilient to change, we could design it in that way. There might be some performance trade-offs, but it could be done.
需要进行标准化，以便我们能够推出安全修复程序并弃用旧协议等。我的意思是，我认为我们可以做到这一点。我认为如果我们坐下来，从一开始就说，嘿，这个库组件需要具备适应变化的能力，我们就可以这样设计它。可能会有一些性能上的权衡，但这是可以做到的。
And I think that oftentimes the conversation in the C++ committee has just been, well, this is an ABI break, so we can't do it. And we maybe need to have more of the conversation of, you know, how could we build, you know, this new component to be resilient? Makes sense. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且我认为，C++ 委员会的讨论往往只是：嗯，这是一个 ABI 破坏，所以我们不能这样做。我们或许需要更多地探讨：你知道，我们如何才能构建这个能够适应变化的新组件？有道理。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢这期节目，祝你有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。